في رد على المقطع الذي نشرته كتائب القسام
للاسرى الثلاثه قال المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان ما بثته حماس هو شريط
ارهابي مضيفا ان اسرائيل تعمل كل شيء
لاعاده المختطفين الذين ظهروا في
الفيديو الشريط الذي بثته حماس هو شريط
ارهابي ويؤكد قسوه حماس على المسنين
الابرياء المحتاجين للعلاج العالم يجب ان
يعمل من اجل ادخال مساعدات طبيه واعاده
المخطوفين ونحن ملتزمون اخلاقيا باعاده
المخطوفين وسنعمل كل شيء من اجل ذلك معنا
الان في الاستديو الدكتور مهند مصطفى
الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه اهلا وسهلا
بك يا دكتور في الواقع اريد ان اتوقف عند
هذا
الفيديو العاده ان فيديوهات التي تبثها
كتائب القسام لا تصل ل
خلال الاعلام الاسرائيلي او للمواطن
الاسرائيلي العادي ولكن هذا الفيديو
تحديدا وصل صحيح هذا الفيديو انتشر في
المواقع الاسرائيليه الاخباريه الهامه
التي يطلع عليها المجتمع الاسرائيلي وتم
عرض الفيديو وصور الرهائن بدون اي تشويش
على على وجوههم بمعنى انه تم تم نشر
الفيديو مع وجوههم على عكس ما كان يفعل
الاعلام الاسرائيلي في السابق يعني اهالي
هؤلاء يعرفون بالض
يعرفون يعرفونهم بالضبط وتعرفوا عليهم
وحتى ان ايه ايه افراد من عائلاتهم خرجوا
الى الاعلام وتحدثوا للاعلام حول هذا
الموضوع واحد من ابناء هؤلاء الرهائن قال
بالحرف الواحد قال انني رايت صوره ابي في
هذا في هذا الفيديو ولم يتواصل احد معي من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه حت حتى هذه اللحظه
وهذا يدل اولا على على التهميش والكذب
التي تدعيه الحكومه الاسرائيليه انها
مهتمه في موضوع الاقصى والرهائن ولذلك
العائلات تخرج الى الشوارع وتتظاهر انها
تعلم ان هذه الحكومه لا تهتم في هذا الملف
لان لم يتم التواصل مع احد حول هذا
الموضوع اصلا لا يتم عقد جلسات ثابته مع
اهالي الاصر والرهائن حول التقدم في موضوع
صفقه او تبادل اسرى اذا كان هذا الامر
مطروح بشكل جدي على على الطاوله هذا
الفيديو سوف يزيد ويخلق حاله من الغضب
والاحتجاج الكبير في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي لسببين اولا انه ه هؤلاء
الرهائن هم كبار في السن اعمارهم فوق
السبين عاما وايضا حرك حماس على ما يبدو
تفهم المجتمع الاسرائيلي كيف بمعنى اولا
الاغنيه الموجوده في الفيديو هذ هذه نقطه
يعني كانت فعلا لافته اول مره نشاهد فيديو
تصاحبه اغنيه في موسيقى نعم وعنوان
الاغنيه الت تشخين العيد ز كناه وهذه
معناها باللغه العبريه لا تت لا تتركون
لشيخها هذه الاغنيه فيها ايضا قاطع اخرى
التي كلها تتحدث عن فكره لا تتركونا
انقذونا لا تتركوني لوحدي ولذلك هذه
الاغنيه مع مع مع عرض هذا الفيديو
للرهائن كبار في السن هذا يؤثر جدا جدا
على المجتمع الاسرائيلي هذا ما تريد حركه
حماس ان تفعله حركه حماس تريد ان تفعل ان
تؤثر على الشارع الاسرائيلي من خلال هذه
الفيديوهات من اجل طرح هذا الموضوع كموضوع
مركزي فيدا المجتمع من القه والاتقان
والاهتمام بكل تفصيل وبكل جزئيه يعني كون
ليس هناك فيديو يخرج هكذا بسرعه لا هناك
بالضبط مثلا نشاهد المثلثات الحمراء التي
تبين الاهداف و طريقه الاخراج الان هذا
الفيديو تحديدا ثلاثه اشخاص وياتي بعد قتل
القوات الاسرائيليه لثلاثه رهائن عن طريق
الخطا يعني لا ياتي اي شيء بالصدفه ربما
الارقام الموسيقى التي تصاحب كل تفصيل
وايضا وايضا الحديث الذي تحدثوا به
الرهائن الثلاث كان موجها بلغه بلغه
مباشره لبنين نتنياهو بمعنى انهم قالوا
ارجعنا لم يقولوا ارجعو بمعنا لم يوجهوا
رسالتهم لكل المجتمع الاسرائيلي وجهوه
للشخص المسؤول عن وضعهم حتى هذه اللحظه في
حركه حماس وهو بن يمين نتنياهو لانه لانه
هنالك اصبح وعي في الشارع الاسرائيلي ان
من يعيق صفقه تبادل اسرى بشكل جدي هو
بنيامين نتنياهو ولذلك الفيديو وكلامهم
وخطابهم موجه الى بنيامين نتنياهو هذا
الامر يعني يحدث تناقد في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي بين الحكومه الاسرائيليه وبين
المجتمع الاسرائيلي المجتمع الاسرائيلي
باغلب يريد صفقه تبادل اسرى اي مع مع حركه
حماس هنالك من من بين المحتجين الذين
يقولون مستعدون لصفقه تبادل الاسرى كل
الاسرى الفلسطينيين مقابل كل الاسرى
والرهائن الاسرائيليين هم مستعدون لذلك
هنالك طيار الان في الشارع الاسرائيلي
يطالب حتى بوقف اطلاق النار كما تريد حماس
من اجل حل مشكله الاصر والرهائن هناك اصبح
قناعه ليلى اصبح قناعه واضحه ان هنالك في
تناقض واضح لا يمكن الجسر بينهما بين
اهداف الحرب بالقضاء على حركه حماس وبين
تحرير الاقصى والرهائن على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ان تختار اما تختار هذا الهدف
او تختار هذا الهدف لا يمكن ان تحقق
الهدفين مع بعضهما البعض ولذلك الضغط في
الشارع الاسرائيلي على حكومه نتنيا سوف
يزداد واحده من شعارات والصور التي يتم
رفعها في المظاهرات الاسرائيليه هي صور
صوره رون اراد رون اراد رون اراد هذا
التيار اسرائيلي اختفى في عام
1988 وتم اسره من قبل
حركات اللبنانيه وتم كان هناك في بدايه
تفاوض من اجل ارجاعه وتم التخلي عنه من من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه
واختفى وحتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم العثور حتى
على وفاته ولذلك هنالك في خشيه في داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي ان يتحول مصير هؤلاء
الاصر والرهائن كمصير رون اراض ولذلك
قالوا في الفيديو في هذه الاغنيه لا
تتركون لوحدنا لا تتركون نشيخ هنا ويتم
تركنا بدون اي حل وهذا لم يخ يعني واضح
انه لم يتم اختياره مصادفه بهذه الطريقه
وسنرى طبعا تاثيره شكرا جزيلا شكرا جزيلا
لوجودك معنا دكتور مهند